à la porte de versailles le salon des
ateliers d'art et de création
le 56ème fait la lumière sur les lampes
sur les abat-jour subtilement rétro
qu'on retrouvera dans la hotte du père
noël
on aime les minéraux et on sait les
utiliser
la liste de ceux qu'on trouve dans ce
salon est sans fin d'autant qu'il faut
compter avec les tissages main vos robes
de tonnes les fleurs des jardins ne sont
pas encore fan et que déjà d'autres
fleurs inventé sont toutes prêtes l'oeil
du visiteur est convié à la porte de
versailles toujours admiré bijour cas le
64e salon vigerie joyeux orfèvrerie
cadeaux avec des montres qui n'ont rien
à cacher avec des bracelets pour homme
avec des pendentifs double usage
enfin avec ses colliers
sans quitter la porte de versailles
plongeon dans la piscine du deuxième
salon du maillot de bain les maillots de
cet été sèche encore et services il y à
déjà la mode 1978 toutes les femmes
peuvent elles vraiment espérer trouver
un maillot la question et ses réponses
je crois que les femmes peuvent trouver
dans les collections
un peu tout
pour être sûr de pouvoir s'habiller des
maillots tr/min et maillots qui leur
donne un air de vente des maillots qui
vont les habiller des maillots qui
seront très classique qui leur donneront
une tenue de rigueur
il ya aussi celles qu'elle nage et et
prennent des maillots nageurs et celles
qui aiment nager bien sûr retrouve le
maillot de six compétitions mais pour
tous ces maillots il y à des robes des
tuniques des jupes
oui des jupes nous pensons qu'un maillot
doit permettre de vivre la détente de
vivre les loisirs et doit être la base
une garde-robe et non pas seulement un
accessoire
où